[Musique]
c'est un mascara un jardin botanique de
la réunion qui ont été installés trois
nouvelles ruches en présence des élèves
de 6e et de 5e du collège de la pointe
des châteaux réserves réelles dans le
cadre de sa compétence en matière de
protection et de valorisation des
espaces naturels sensibles le
département invalide un partenariat avec
l'unaf l'union nationale de l'apiculture
française un programme d'envergure
intitulée abeille sentinelle de
l'environnement pour la sauvegarde de
l'abeille et de la biodiversité sur tout
le territoire français à travers
l'installation de ruches et pédagogique
alors le département a tenu aujourd'hui
à créer ce partenariat avec l'union
nationale des apiculteurs de france en
incluant des collèges pour inculquer et
aussi pour sensibiliser les scolaires
qui sont nos futurs ambassadeurs dans le
cadre de la préservation de la bei
préservation de la biodiversité
depuis plusieurs semaines les collégiens
de la pointe des châteaux sont
sensibilisés au rôle essentiel de la bei
avec une opération du rucher pédagogique
qui peuvent mieux les observer découvrir
le travail des apiculteurs et obtenir
des réponses à leurs questions
ils ont également planté des espèces
endémiques et indigènes mellifères
autour du rucher pédagogique
j'ai appelé bout j'ai appris beaucoup de
choses par bon
j'ai appris par exemple que la reine ne
sortait pas enfin j'ai appris beaucoup
beaucoup de choses justes en en quelques
heures
c'est je trouve que que c'est très
intéressant les abeilles c'est quand
même ce qui nous permet d'assommer da
nous permet de vivre une aussi c'est
important et elles sont en ce moment on
va c'est en danger est donc vraiment et
les salles à monter à faire des actions
peau de voir les les protéger alors on
peut y aller avec lesquels continuent à
butiner et caetera et comme dans son
union elles sont assez en dj je voulais
venir parce que c'est intéressant de
voir comment on pourrait les aider ou
leur appartement dans leur état naturel
alors il faut être sensibilisés
notamment aux abeilles et aux différents
riche et parce que ce sont comme
l'indiquent le nom du projet sentinelle
de l'environnement
sans abeilles on l'être humain ne
pourrait pas être là et ses abeilles qui
sont en fait les les ouvrières de notre
écosystème
son
une forme de clé de voûte de
l'environnement donc sensibiliser les
élèves au développement durable et
sensibiliser les élèves à l'écologie
c'est aussi sensibiliser des élèves ou à
l'existence et au travail des abeilles
les départements s'efforce de favoriser
l'installation de ruches sur ces espaces
naturels sensibles
quarante huit emplacements pouvant
accueillir jusqu'à 40 ruchers ont été
attribués à des apiculteurs sur toute
l'île
[Musique]